Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Türkiye buradan bakınca dünyanın
merkezinde gibi gözüküyor, değil mi?
Oysa birtakım teknik sorunlarımız var,
bilimsel sorunlarımız var.
Bırakın Amerika'yla
Batı Avrupa'yla yarışmayı;
nüfusunun %77'si köylerde yaşayan
1 milyar kişi, köylerde yaşayan Hindistan
2014 yılında Mars yörüngesine
uydu gönderdi
ve oradan bilimsel veri topluyor.
Bizde bir şeyler eksik.
Bir şeylerimiz eksik.
Ne yapabiliriz? Neyimiz eksik?
Bunu düşündük, düşündüm,
birkaç madde buldum.
Bazen ben, bazen biz diyeceğim;
burada genelde biz dediğimde
öğrencilerim ve beni,
meslektaşlarım ve beni kastedeceğim.
Bulduğumuz şeyler bunlardı:
Bilgi eksikliğimiz var,
teknik altyapı eksikliğimiz var,
motivasyon eksikliğimiz var.
Şimdi Türkiye Avrupa’nın bir parçası,
tabii ki kendimize has çözümler
üretelim de;
parçası olduğumuz Avrupa,
tarihinde ne yaşamış,
ne olmuş ona bakalım.
Belki alabileceğimiz dersler vardır.
Aslında Avrupa, İkinci Dünya Savaşı'ndan
hemen sonra benzeri,
hatta çok daha kötü bir durumdaymış.
Avrupa yıkılmış,
birbirinin boğazına sarılan ülkeler,
ülkelerin altyapılarını yok ettiği gibi,
bilim adamlarının da
Amerika’ya kaçmasına sebep olmuş.
Fakat savaşın hemen ardından
insanlar bir araya gelmişler.
1949 yılında Lozan’da
bir kültür konferansı düzenlenmiş.
Bu kültür konferansında önceden hukukçu
sonradan fizikçi olan,
Nobel ödüllü Louis de Broglie
bir öneri yapmış,
demiş ki,
"Parçalanmış olan Avrupa’yı
bilim etrafında birleştirelim."
Bu öneri hem bilim adamları,
hem de politikacılar arasında
çok beğeni toplamış.
1953 yılında, bildiğiniz kurumun,
CERN’ün kuruluş antlaşması imzalanmış.
1954 yılında da Cenevre’de,
İsviçre-Fransa sınırında
kurulacak olan laboratuvarın
ilk temel atma töreni yapılmış.
CERN dört ana esas üzerine kurulmuş.
Bu esasların tabii en önemlisi,
bilimin sınırlarını zorlamak.
Çalıştığımız konu nedir:
"Maddenin temel yapı taşları nedir?"
Bu soruya cevap arıyoruz.
Buna cevap ararken evrenin
ilk anları hakkında fikir sahibi oluyoruz.
Madde ve enerji hakkında
fikir sahibi oluyoruz.
Bunların etkileşimi hakkında
Bunu gerçekleştirebilmek için
iki tane alete ihtiyacımız var:
Hızlandırıcı ve algıç.
Türkçe önemli; "dedektör" değil, "algıç".
Hızlandırıcılar nasıl çalışıyor?
Algıçlar nasıl çalışıyor?
Çok çok basit, size söyleyeyim.
Bizim çalışma yöntemimiz
3 yaşındaki çocukla aynı.
Şu aletin ne olduğunu
merak eden çocuk -oyuncağının-
duvara fırlatır kırar,
içinde ne var diye bakar.
Bizim yapmaya çalıştığımız şey de bu.
Hızlandırıcılarla protonun içinde
ne olduğunu merak ediyoruz.
Hızlandırıcılarla protonu hızlandırıp
ya duvara, bir hedefe
ya da başka bir protona çarptırıyoruz.
Dışarıya saçılan, içinde ne varsa artık,
bakmak için de çok büyük fotoğraf
makinaları, algıçlar kullanıyoruz.
Dolayısıyla bu teknolojilerin,
bakkaldan alınamayacağına göre,
geliştirilmesi lazım.
Bunun yanı sıra başka şeyler de
çıkıyor, bundan ileride bahsedeceğim.
Üçüncü konu: Bütün bunların
yapılabilmesi için ihtiyaç duyulan
bilimsel ve mühendislik dallarında
yetişmiş insan gücünü hazırlamak.
Bazı bilgiler okuyarak değil de
usta-çırak ilişkisiyle elde ediliyor.
Dolayısıyla bu tecrübenin
aktarılması çok önemli
ve son olarak da,
CERN'ün yine esas amacı,
unutmayalım
Louis de Broglie neden önermişti?
Farklı kültür ve ülkelerden
insanları bir araya getirmek.
Soğuk Savaş zamanında,
Sovyet ve Amerikan bilim adamlarının
birlikte çalıştığı
tek yer CERN.
Bugün de, gençler arasında
İsrail-Filistin partileri...
U-huu hiçbir şey söylemiyorum,
ama çok çok meşhur.
CERN ilk başladığında proje olarak,
demiş ki bir hızlandırıcı yapayım.
Bununla başlamış; ilk CERN hızlandırıcısı
gördüğünüz gibi iki adam boyunda.
Bugünse yaklaşık 12 bin kişinin çalıştığı,
iki tane büyük yerleşkesi olan,
en büyük hızlandırıcıyı
size sarı renkle gösterdiğim,
kendi adına Avrupa Nükleer
Araştırma Merkezi diyen,
ama benim bilimin ve bilimsel teknolojinin
dünyadaki tek merkezi dediğim yer.
Bütçemiz yaklaşık
bir milyar İsviçre Frangı.
Bugünlerde bire üç.
Bu hızlandırıcıyı tabii
basından biliyorsunuz muhtemelen,
Büyük Hadron Çarpıştırıcısı Higgs falan
ama bunu bir spor arabanın
en son vitesi gibi düşünebilirsiniz.
Siz spor arabayı altıncı vitesle giderken
gördünüz, ama bunun öncesi var,
bunun öncesinde
bir hızlandırıcı kompleksi var
ve hepsinin başladığı yer,
birinci vitesi de,
en altta LINAC sözüyle gördüğünüz,
doğrusal hızlandırıcı,
İngilizcesi Linear Accelerator,
doğrusal hızlandırıcılar.
Bu doğrusal hızlandırıcıyı aklınızda tutun
lütfen ileride gelmeye çalışacağım tekrar.
Şimdi, dışarıya çıkan
çarpışma sonucu parçaları
fotoğraf makinalarıyla
görmeye çalışıyoruz dedim.
Bu fotoğraf makinaları neye benziyor
diyecek olursanız, bunlar büyük deneyler.
Mesela burada bir tanesini Atlas deneyini,
benim çalıştığım deneyi görüyorsunuz.
Önünde bir tane teknisyen var üzgünüm,
yeterince belki çekici değil ama
bir teknisyenle boyu konusunda
fikir vermeye çalıştım.
Bu bir silindir,
uzunluğu yaklaşık 40 metre,
yüksekliği de 22 metre olan bir silindir.
Bunun içindeki farklı algıçlarla
dışarıya çıkan parçacıkları inceleyip
evrenin yapı taşları konusunda
fikir sahibi olmaya çalışıyoruz.
Bakın burada size
bir özet tablo hazırladım.
Solda gördüğünüz kutular,
evreni oluşturan temel yapı taşları.
Sağdaki silindirler de,
onların birbirleri ile etkileşmesini
sağlayan parçacıklar.
Liseden hatırladığımız periyodik tabloyu
buraya kadar indirebildik,
çünkü periyodik tablodaki her şeyi
bunlardan yola çıkarak yapabiliyoruz
ve daha da fazlasını.
Bu kadar bilimsel çalışma
nereye getirdi bizi?
Birçok Nobel ödülü kazandı CERN, üç tane.
Bir tanesi W ve Z Bozonlarının keşfiyle
Carlo Rubbia
ve bu makinanın çalışma prensibiyle
Van der Meer'e verildi.
60'lı yıllarda yaptığı parçacık algıcığı
çalışmasıyla Georges Charpak
92 yılında aldı, 30 yıl sonra.
Higgs ve Englert,
yine 60'lı yıllarda Higgs parçacığının
kuramsal temellerini atmışlardı,
ancak Nobel ödülü
çok çok uzun soluklu bir şey.
Çalışmalar çok çok uzun soluklu,
keşfi 2012,
Nobel ödülü 2013.
Hayatta kalmak lazım
Nobel ödülünü alabilmek için,
çünkü yaşayanlara veriliyor sadece.
Bütün bunların birtakım
teknolojik getirileri de var,
tamam havadan yiyecek yapamıyoruz,
Star Trek değil henüz,
ne bileyim mükemmel eşi de bulamıyoruz,
ama birkaç şey yapabiliyoruz.
Bir tanesini tabii çok iyi biliyorsunuz:
World Wide Web,
bugün olmadan olmayan,
yaşayamadığımız bir şey.
Tabii bu CERN'de icat edilmiş bir şey,
çünkü birkaç yüz değişik milletten
birkaç bin değişik araştırmacının
kolaylıkla birbirleriyle
veri alışverişi yapması lazım.
Bu o sayede,
o yüzden icat edilmiş bir şey.
Bunun yanında, tabii bu durmadı ilerledi
sadece bilgi değil,
hesap gücü de paylaşalım denildi
ve grit, Türkçe'ye örgü diye çevirdik,
diye bir kavram ortaya atıldı.
Burada, dediğim gibi,
hesap gücü paylaşılıyor
bunun bilimsel getirisinin yanı sıra,
Türkiye'yi çok ilgilendiren
bir uygulaması var:
Bir deprem olduktan sonra,
o depremin analizi
çok hızlı bir şekide yapılıp
depremin nerede başladığı,
ne cins bir deprem olduğu
kolaylıkla tespit edilebiliyor
ve bunun kurtarma çalışmaları
üzerinde çok olumlu etkisi var.
Tıp konusunda iki örnek vereceğim:
Bir tanesi tanı,
Positron Emission Tomography.
Hızlandırıcılarda hazırlanmış,
çok kısa yarı ömrü olan
yapay radyoaktif elementler
insan vücuduna veriliyor, zerk ediliyor
ve bunlar kullanılarak,
insan vücudu açılmadan,
organların nasıl çalıştığı görülebiliyor.
Yine hızlandırıcıların bir uygulaması
olarak Proton tedavisi var,
bu da söz gelimi vücudun derinliklerindeki
bir kanserli tümörün,
vücudun üst kısmına zarar vermeden
yok edilmesi anlamına geliyor.
Bütün bunları söylerken
hep hızlandırıcı hızlandırıcı dedim,
burayı biliyor musunuz?
Evet, evet, teşekkür ederim,
burası Louvre.
Eğer Dan Brown'un kitaplarını okuduysanız,
Cam Piramit'in altında
bir mezar bekliyor olabilirsiniz.
(Kahkaha)
Bu var cam piramidin altında,
bir hızlandırıcı.
Bu hızlandırıcı ne işe yarıyor,
neden orada diyecek olursanız
sebebi basit:
Tarihi eserlerin,
sanat eserlerinin iç yapılarını
onlara zarar vermeden
tespit etmekte kullanılıyor.
Eğer bu sunumdan, benim sunumumdan,
eve iki şey götürecekseniz;
ikincisi, hızlandırıcıların
21. yüzyılın anahtar teknolojisi olduğu,
İsviçre çakısı olduğu olsun,
çünkü sadece bilim alanında değil,
şurada göstermeye çalıştım.
Tıpta %40,
telefonlardaki, bilgisayarlardaki
yarı iletken malzemenin,
işlemcilerin hazırlanmasında,
"ion implentation"
deniyor %40 kullanılıyor.
Bilimsel amaçla, temel bilim için
kullanılan hızlandırıcı sayısı %1.
Bu ikinci şeydi.
Birinci şey de,
hareket başlatmaktan çekinmeyin olsun,
çünkü Louis de Broglie'nin
attığı fikir bizi nereye getirdi.
Avrupa'yı birleştirelim diye
yola çıkmıştık;
insan vücudunun içini anlamaktan,
tümör, kanser tedavi, deprem...
Nerelere gideceğini
insan kestiremiyor bile önceden.
Şimdi hareket başlatmaktan
çekinmeyin de,
ne yapmamız lazım?
Üretmek istiyorsak şayet,
elimizi kirletmekten çekinmeyeceğiz.
Öğrenmek istiyorsak,
temel bilimlere gitmekten çekinmeyeceğiz.
Öğretmek istiyorsak; bilimsel düşünmekten,
deney yapmaktan,
çevremizi anlatmaktan çekinmeyeceğiz.
Şimdi bu noktada da bana
hissediyorum şunu diyeceksiniz:
Öğüt vermek kolay, sen ne yaptın?
Biz de bir şeyler yapmaya çalıştık
öğrencilerim ve meslektaşlarımla.
En kolaydan başlayarak,
en kolay da şu oluyor:
Eğer bir şeyi biliyorsam, hiç olmazsa
etrafımdakilere öğretebilirim.
Dolayısıyla yarının araştırmacıları olan
bugünün yüksek lisans
ve doktora öğrencileri için
Türkiye'nin birkaç yerinde,
en güzeli bence Kars'tı,
-30 derecede çok iyi fizik yapılıyor.
(Kahkaha)
Kış kampları düzenledik.
Geleceğin araştırmacıları ise
bugün gördüğünüz minik arkadaşlarım,
ortaokul, lise öğrencileri.
Onlara doğrudan bir şey anlatmaktansa,
bunu yapmanın başka bir yolu var.
Onların öğretmenlerini heyecanlandırmak,
bilim ateşini onlara aktarmak
ki biz 1'den 10'a aktarırken
onlar da 10'u 10.000 yapsın.
Dolayısıyla üç yıl önce
bir program başlattık,
Türk Öğretmen Çalıştayı dedik adına.
Türkiye'den, çeşitli yerlerinden
haritada gördüğünüz gibi,
öğretmenleri bir hafta
CERN'de misafir ettik,
bizim çalışmalarımızın heyecanını gördüler
ve yazdıkları notlara göre
hayatlarının, bilimsel hayatlarının
eğitim, akademik hayatlarının
en heyecanlı, en verimli
birer haftasını geçirdiler.
Şimdiye kadar bu çalıştaya katılan
öğretmen sayısı yaklaşık 200
ve iki hafta sonra da altıncısını
yapmak üzere çalışmaya devam ediyoruz.
Teknik altyapı konusunda da
izninizle birkaç şey söyleyeceğim.
CERN'ün hızlandırıcılarını
nasıl başladığını,
birinci vitesin ne olduğunu
hatırlayın; doğrusal hızlandırıcı.
CERN'ün nasıl başladığını hatırlayın:
Bir hızlandırıcı yaparak.
O hâlde dedik ki madem Türkiye için
bir şey yapmak istiyoruz,
biz de bir hızlandırıcı yapalım.
Türkiye Atom Enerjisi Kurumu'nun
ev sahipliğinde ve idaresinde
bir hızlandırıcı yapmaya oturduk.
Bu proje Ankara'da gerçekleşiyor
ve ana fikir de şu:
Küçük olsun, bizim olsun.
Biz tasarlayalım, biz üretelim,
biz öğrenelim.
Bunu yapmaya kalktığımız zaman
şunu gördük.
Tamam, proton hızlandırıcısı yapmak için
belli birtakım
geliştirilen yazılımlar var.
Bunu satın almaya kalktığımızda,
bu yazılımların hak sahibi olan,
geliştirmiş olan ülkeler Amerika, Fransa,
Türkiye'ye satmayı reddettiler,
çünkü Türkiye kara listedeymiş.
"Kuzey Kore, Sudan, İran, Türkiye
kara listede, size kesinlikle satmıyoruz."
Tasarımı olmadan,
bilgisayar olmadan bu işler yapılmaz.
Ne yapalım derken
öğrencilerimle beraber dedik ki:
Ya onlar da yapabilir, yapmış.
Ben de yapabilirim, ben de insanım.
Çekinecek bir şey yok, atıl!
Oturduk, kendi hızlandırıcı
tasarım yazılımımızı oluşturduk.
TÜBİTAK bizi destekledi.
Yaklaşık iki yıllık bir projeyle.
Simgemizi gördünüz: Demir döven adam.
Neticede hızlandırıcılar metalden
yapılıyor, metal-demir, hmm.
(Kahkaha)
Bu projeyi konferanslarda
öğrencilerim sunduğu zaman
bu sefer Amerikalılar geldiler,
"Biz size software'imizi satmaya hazırız,
yazılımımızı satmaya hazırız" diye.
Eğer siz bir şey üretirseniz,
tasarım aşamasında dahi
elinizde müthiş bir pazarlık payı oluyor.
Neyse, bu proje belli bir yere geldi,
ikinci sunumu,
ikinci gösteriyi Çin'de yaptılar.
Bu sefer Çinliler geldi, bunu ticari hâle
getirin de biz sizden satın alalım diye.
Bence bu fena olmayan bir başarıydı.
Bir başka şey,
hızlandırıcı yaparken bu alet gerekiyor.
Bu alet nedir diyecek olursanız,
elektromanyetik dalgaların
işte çarptığı zaman geri geldiğinde
güç kaynağına zarar vermemesini
sağlayan bir aygıt.
Biz buna dolaştırıcı dedik Türkçe'sine.
Bunu satın alalım dedik
bir Amerikan firmasında.
Bize 250 bin dolar fiyat teklif ettiler.
O kadar bütçemiz yok; ne yapacağız,
kendimiz tasarlayacağız,
kendimiz üreteceğiz, peki.
Tasarımı yapıp
bunu üreteceğiz diye bir konferansa
gittiğimizde aynı firma geldi,
bizi buldu ve dedi ki
"%10'una sizindir, üretmenize gerek yok".
Ama bu olmaz,
çünkü üretirken elde ettiğiniz deneyim,
kazandığınız deneyim paha biçilmez.
Dolayısıyla gördüğünüz gibi ürettik
ve oraya koyduk.
Gelelim işletme kısmına.
(Alkış)
Bir şeyi üretirsiniz,
elinizde vardır satın alırsınız,
ama işletme çok önemli,
bakın Kurtuluş Savaşı'nda elimizde
tren vardı, ama makinist yoktu.
Bir aleti yapmak yeterli değil,
onu kullanabilecek insanları da
yetiştirmek çok önemli.
Bizim Ankara'daki laboratuvarda insanlar
aynı zamanda bu aletleri
kullanmayı da öğreniyorlar
ve bizim ekipten ayrılan bir başka genç
mesela bu işi ticari olarak yapabilir
miyim diye endüstride çalışmaya başladı,
bu benim çok çok
hoşuma giden bir gelişme oldu.
Son olarak motivasyon hakkında
bir şey söyleyeceğim.
Motivasyon nedir, başarılı olmamız lazım
ki insanları motive edelim.
Bence başarılı olmanın sırrı şu:
Mümkün olduğunca
büyük bir lokma ısırmak lazım,
ama yutabileceğiniz kadar da küçük olmalı.
Mümkün olduğunca büyük,
yutabileceğiniz kadar küçük.
Bana öyle geliyor ki
bizim Ankara'daki hızlandırıcı
Atom Enerjisi Kurumu'nun
yaptığı hızlandırıcı böyle bir şey.
Bizim laboratuvarın
son hâlini arkada görüyorsunuz.
Sol yukarıda gördüğünüz proton kaynağımız,
ışıldamasını görüyorsunuz belki,
sağda gördüğünüzse 2015 yılının sonunda
elde ettiğimiz ilk proton demeti.
Henüz hızlandırıcıya girmedi,
çünkü hızlandırıcı kovuk.
Tabii bizim tasarladığımız ürettiğimiz
kovuk, ortada duran sarı şey,
henüz test masasında.
Aslında ben de pazartesi günü Ankara'ya
bu proje üzerinde çalışmaya gidiyorum.
(Alkış)
Bu ekip İstanbul'dan,
Ankara'dan, Eskişehir'den
birkaç tane de Cenevre'den insanların
uzaktan birbirleriyle etkileşerek
gerçekleştirdiği bir şey.
Evet, Louis de Broglie'nin başlattığı
harekete belki çok yakın değil,
belki birazcık benziyor.
Bakalım 40 yıl sonra biz nerede olacağız?
Ama söyleyeceğim şu,
biz çekinmedik atıldık.
Siz de sakın kendinize olan
inancınızı yitirmeyin,
yapabilirsiniz!
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)